the longest Star Wars movie so far the
last Jedi is densely packed with tons of
details and easter eggs even some
diehard fans may have missed on a first
viewing yippie Kay may be lovers it's
Jan here and today I want to talk about
some fascinating references and hidden
details and episode dates that have more
significance than you might have
initially realized and if you're new to
my channel I do regular Easter egg
videos movie breakdowns theories and
deleted scenes plus giveaways to enter
my current Star Wars giveaway just make
sure you're subscribed and leave me a
comment about any Easter eggs or
interesting details you spotted in the
film spoiler warning I will be
discussing scenes from the last Jedi in
depth so take care if you haven't seen
the movie yet after Yoda returned as a
force ghost reuniting with Luke on act
to the legendary Jedi Master burned down
the islands ancient force tree and when
Luke protested about the destruction of
the sacred Jedi Tex and Yoda replied
that there was nothing in there that the
girl rave does not already possess it
seems that the ancient Burke's had
burned with the tree but that Ray had
already mastered everything in them
however Yoda's words actually had
another meaning which became clear at
the end of the movie there's a crucial
moment on the Millennium Falcon when
Finn opens a drawer to get a blanket to
cover the injured Rose Tico and as he
rummages around you can spot the Jedi
books right there meaning that Rey
actually took them from the island so
Yoda's reply to Luke was a clever bit of
wordplay and suggests that Rey has more
to learn of course it also means that
Rey and the resistance still have the
old Jedi scripts which they can use to
inspire and teach new force users about
the Jedi way near the start of the film
Rey tells Luke that the resistance needs
his help to face their enemies and he
replies you think what I'm going to walk
out with a laser sword and face down the
whole first-order luke's use of the word
laser sword is an easter egg to George
Lucas's early Star Wars scripts where
that term was used instead of light
saber and in the Phantom Menace we hear
the same term used by young Anakin
Skywalker as well as containing a hat
tip to the sagas origins Luke's replied
to Rey also foreshadows the end of the
movie in contrast to what he said Luke
does indeed walk out armed with just a
lightsaber and confront the entire first
order and yet Luke also stays true to
his original words to Rey because it's
not actually his physical
who faces down the first-order but
rather a force projection ACTU is home
to the first Jedi Temple which has a
curious ancient mosaic on its floor of
the Prime Jedi the very first member of
the Jedi Order the mosaics design is
reminiscent of a yin-yang symbol and
shows the Prime Jedi in a state of
meditation and balance which foreshadows
Luke's own position on the island at the
end of the movie the image also shows a
fusion of light and dark which is
interesting because in the last Jedi ray
and kylo Ren form a force bond between
them and kylo RA to join him of course
the mosaic also symbolizes a tension
that force users experience between
being pulled between the light and the
dark sides for example kylo struggles
with his connection to the dark side and
experiences a pull to the light as he
calls it there's a clear parallel
between the hole that Rey climbs into on
the Jedi Temple island and the darkside
cave that Luke entered during his
training on Dagobah both the caves
forced the entrant to confront their
worst fear for Luke this appeared to be
the evil that Darth Vader represented
but when the cave exposed Luke's face
inside Vader's helmet
it showed that Luke's real fear was that
he might turn to the dark side and it's
also foreshadowed the revealed that he
was Darth Vader's son well though we
don't hear the reveal of Rey's parents
until later in the last Jedi we do get
an interesting bit of foreshadowing by a
raise experienced in the cave Ray's
always been waiting for her parents to
return to her but when she sees her own
image endlessly reflected back to her it
foreshadows the discovery later that
she's actually known the answer within
herself all along in other words she is
alone borås Maz Kanata said in the force
awakens whomever you're waiting for
they're never coming back in a callback
to the time Luke crash-landed in a swamp
on Dagobah in the Empire Strikes Back
there's a submerged x-wing on the shores
of the Jedi Temple island and Luke has
salvaged and s foil from that underwater
x-wing to make a door for his stone
hearse on act 2 in the last Jedi we get
to meet Snoke close up and although we
still don't know his backstory there's
one item he owns which reveals some
secrets about his connection to the
darkside the gold ring the supreme
leader was on his finger is etched with
symbols of the four sages of duarte the
four sages were philosophers from the
planet duarte who in the
early days of the Republic stirred
controversy promoted the study of the
dark side of the force and were popular
among the Sith in fact Palpatine had
snatches them in his office in attack of
the clans Snoke also has a link to
another legendary Sith Lord as the black
stone in the ring is actually obsidian
mined from the catacombs below Darth
Vader's cast along a volcanic planet
Mustafar which was also the location of
Anakin and obi-wan fateful duel in
Revenge of the Sith the way poe dameron
toys with general hooks at the start of
the film pretending he can't hear him
and waiting for you patched through by
hooks his communication officer is
reminiscent of the start of the force
awakens who were poe made fun of kylo
Ren after being captured asking who
should talk first and saying it was hard
to understand him through the mask and
in the last Jedi post line tell hooks
Leia has an urgent message for him about
his mother is a dig at the fact that
hooks is an illegitimate child whose
mother was a kitchen worker a fact which
was revealed in a recent Canon Star Wars
novel speaking of Poe after he struck up
a bromance with ex stormtrooper Finn in
the force awakens it was nice to see
them reunite when Finn woke up and is
back to suit and after thing got dressed
he donned Poe's old jacket which if you
look carefully you can see has been
repaired after Finn's run-in with kylo
Ren in Episode seven in fact it was PO
who stitched the jacket back up while
Finn was recovering a detail I'm sure
fans of storm pilot will particularly
like bb-8 got to do some pretty cool
things in the last Jedi and while on
board the supremacy Finn disguised him
with a black metal can making him
resemble a rather large Mouse droid
he even scoots along making noises that
are uncannily similar and matched the
pattern made by an MSc six repair droid
in a new hope to top it all bb-8 also
bumps into a stormtrooper on the
supremacy just like the mouse droid ran
into Han and Luke disguised the
stormtroopers alongside Chewie in
Episode four after layer recovers from
her time in space there's a nice
callback to one of her first scenes in a
new hope when she bursts through the
door to confront the mutinous Poe
Dameron she's dressed in white like we
saw her in episode 4 and she uses her
blaster in stunned mode on poe sending
out blue circular blasts just how the
stormtroopers blasted Leia to catch her
at the beginning of a new hope
laya scenes in the last Jedi have of
course taken on an adenine see since
Carrie Fisher passed away and although
it's unclear what exactly will happen
with lair in episode 9 episode 8 was a
real Fisher family affair with both her
daughter Billie lourd playing lieutenant
conics again and the additional bonus
for space cameo by Carrie's dog Gary
look out for him on canto bite in the
casino scene where an alien dog appears
whose design was based on the much-loved
actresses famous pet during the battle
on crate the Millennium Falcon loses its
radar dish again this Chewie tries to
outmaneuver some Thai fighters the ship
gets caught in a tight spot in some
underground caves and one of the TIE
fighters gets a shot on the sensor dish
blasting it off the original circular
sensor was lost when Lando flew the
Falcon in Return of the Jedi the
astonishing ending to the last Jedi also
has some important Easter eggs and
callbacks from binary sunsets on
Tatooine to sis force projections and
Luke becoming one with the force I go
into detail on these and more and my
last Jedi ending explained video as well
as talking theories on episode 9 if you
haven't seen that yet just tap in the
top right to watch or click the link in
the video description below
now did you spot any cool details or
Easter eggs in the movie and what were
your favorite moments leave me a comment
below and make sure you subscribe to
enter my Star Wars giveaway for an
awesome last Jedi Funko pop I've got
more lost Jedi videos on the way so 10
on notifications to keep up to date and
in the meantime check out more of my
videos you are sure to like here thanks
for watching and see you next time
you PK movie lovers